هذه اللحظه ما سجل هو وسقوط 12 مبنى في
بلدات حارم وسلقين والاتارب وايضا بلده
جنديرس هذه المباني هي كانت ايله ومهدده
بالسقوط ويبدو انها تاثرت بفعل هذا
الزلزال بالنسبه للمدن التي لم تصبها
اضرار جسيمه سقطت بعض النوافذ وواجهات
المباني وغيرها ما تسبب بجروح لدى سكان
المنطقه الذين كانوا في الشوارع المؤكد
حتى اللحظه هي 55 اصابه فقط ممن القوا
بانفسهم من النوافل ومن شرفات منازلهم
نتيجه الخوف تحدث عن رقم حقيقه كبير
مقارنه ب130 اصابه في شمال غرب سوريا حتى
اللحظه الرقم مرجح طبعا بشكل كبير للزياده
لان لا تزال هناك توافد كبير على
المستشفيات في المناطق الداخليه من شمال
غرب سوريا لان المستشفيات هناك هناك نقطه
مهمه للمستشفيات التي كانت متواجده في
المناطق التي تضررت بشكل كبير بفعل
الزلزال على الحدود السوريه التركيه
يبدو انها سيتم اخلائها خلال ساعات
القليله القادمه لانها كانت اصلا متضرره
متفضعه وكانت تقوم بعمليات الاخلاء العاجل
او الاسعافات الاوليه في خيام وضعت على
ابواب هذه المستشفيات ثم يتم نقل المصابين
الى المستشفيات الداخليه الامنه نسبيا